tutti ragazzi vedrete che sono video
sono fa vigente che oggi sono tornati su
super ragazzo di carne o super carne
ragazzo è un gioco no supercar nei
ragazzi romani mastica no che l'aveva
fatta sta roba non mi prendete per il
culo che l'ho già fatta non mi fate di
far le cose
la battuta 1 alla battuta ma io l'ho
battuto stronzo cioè noi che doveri fast
a grado di farlo ma come ma l'ho già
fatto e lo scott ma non ne valeva la
sentite è già non riesco a far le cose
famiglia legato all'amore di dio è già
difficile sto cazzo di gioca almeno non
far lasciam perdere lasciam perdere che
è meglio non ho vinto grazie muori anche
tua madre grazie perfetto ce l'ho fatto
ragazzi per la seconda [ __ ] volta che
doppio clic resca a quella madonna
ovvero cliccare esche ragazzi mi sono
rifatto un livello che ci ho messo venti
buoni minuti gli scadesse il tartufo
comunque ragazzi dal secondo livello che
dovevo fare che non ci sono arrivato ma
vabbè adesso vola all estero
the hospital a quello era un ospedale si
certo volevo dirvi ragazzi che è che
bello ma figo proprio c'è non le posso
toccare ste cose immagino novero
perfetto per madonna cui mi sono salvato
ok calmi calmi tutti caldeggiamo ci
volevo dirvi ragazzi prima di natale che
sarà impossibile che io riesco a finire
tutto questo giro esiste sono forbici
che tagliano t'ammazzo nel primo
episodio ragazzi che eravamo nella
foresta sono riuscito a finire tutti
quanti i livelli ma qua non credo di
riuscire a finirli tutti perché c'è il
primo era semplice in confronto a questo
molto più semplice ma veramente tanto i
ragazzi non ci arrivo come dovrei fare
sta roba
agi ok ci sono sì sì ok calmi che ce lo
fa allora ragazzi molto semplice
concetto è questo gioco è una merda che
è una merda di quella mia b quella melma
per chi è ma che sono i problemi ai no
scherzavo che poi a me la prendo con il
gioco ma poi rino gioco è bello sono io
che sono stufa beh questo non c'erano
dubbi che fossi stupì avrò
poi sono mentito ragazzi non è che non
riesco a fare tutto il capitolo di
livelli faccio un rischio fare anche
solo il primo set
ok come non perfetto ma la merda di meat
boy che che si suicida a caso è vero che
al prossimo livello è stato c'è
difficile questo perfetto di prossimo in
un tentativo solo proprio non a caso si
sporca
mi sono fatto anche malissimo nel darmi
nano manata ci stavo riuscendo al primo
tentativo sarebbe stato grave ma secondo
ha piu ha piu non l'ho mai preso neanche
a scuola questo cioè quello di prima ci
ho messo degli anni questo fatto ma è
così ragazzi si giochi ogni tanto a ogni
tanto viene da insultare le famiglie ma
i normali cioè uno che mi fissa qua
sopra ci inquieta chi cazzo è questo
vabbè lasciamo perda andiamo avanti
comunque il tipo andato nello speed
continuerà a rubarmi la tipa quel
bastardo è un po come supermario cedetti
pari via la principessa poi non la trovi
mai è impossibile se no no no perché si
vuole cosa ho fatto
ok ok a più pure la più ragazzi ormai è
troppo anche ragazzi mi sono dimenticato
di dirvi all'inizio del video che non ve
l'ho detto ma sono sorpreso di quanto
sia andato bene super meat boy che è un
gioco che non avevo fatto fino adesso e
ci sarà un motivo comunque ragazzi una
roba che cazzo che mi mandi messaggi
mentre sto giocando al super meat boy
che già sono incazzato
ti prego bravo grado devo andare a
queste sono deficienti c è diventata una
roba ingestibile ormai di qua avercela
l'altro 29 però preso la supposta vedi a
volte prenderla nel culo servo c'è un ok
ok ma perché non salti dio santo meat
boy spiegamelo ti prego ho bisogno
ok perfetto non scherzavo non so come ho
fatto ma va bene così
di qua giusto senza morire anche una
volta una volta dovrò fare un livello a
non morire ma anche una mezza volta e
sarà questa no non sarà questa la volta
che ci riesco continua libido in mutande
però non sarà oggi spero ma vedo di
morire apposta una volta per non fare il
video in mutande ecco è infatti ma
perché ma come ho fatto a chiedergli un
buco di merda non c'entro mai il buco
perché adesso sì non pensate
ai ragazzi stavo schiaccerà nel senso va
beh avete capito come dovrei farlo è
imposta che sentite non si può saltare
sta merda è assurdo non si può saltare
vero così non lo so non salterò comunque
perché io devo io posso io posso
si no ok cosa piangi in culo piazzavo
scherza è stato scherzare non si sa mai
che va bene e fa fatti toccare vedi
questo dovrebbe essere il mio birillo
alla mia mano a penso fosse il caso
dritto vabbè che poi ragazzi è una
storia d'amore stranissima perché tra i
due ce l'ho io il mestro io sono il
maschio è impossibile tocchiamo la zia
perfetto ah che bello poi è arrivato il
maniaco come la sola va beh sono storie
d'amore comunque migliori di twilight
questo è sicuro cioè una roba del tipo
che noi che cazzo si cosi simon pokémon
sembra un incrocio tra detto è un pezzo
di me è come ardito perfetto su quali
sono i muri che posso toccare i quali no
però è la sopra e là sopra la [ __ ] la
bella ragazza è sì sì sì ce l'ho fatto
non è stato neanche così tragico la fee
perché è buio ragazzi sito livello e
buio a caso a me lo fa non so fare lo
stesso anche se buio e cosa credono
perfetto più tutti gli horror ai quali
ho giocato potrei giocare anche senza lo
schermo proprio bicuadro passare la mano
a cosa ho fatto
no ma perché ma perché mi è successo tre
volte già oggi è assurda sta cosa almeno
fatemi morire prima di morire alla fine
no no no non lo sapevo già che stavo
primo riportiamo un mio amico al
telefono e gli dico sei uno stronzo di
merda perché dovevo sfogarmi
cosa che a casa roba c'è uno che lecca a
ci sono anch'io che se chi è batman cioè
a c'è anche la mia tipa che se successo
che cos'è acciai tacchi la tizia chi sia
indirizzato l'uccello adesso vuole
leccare la mia tizia veramente a me sono
io
io sono batman ragazzi cosa cazzo è
successo voglio delle spiegazioni vi
prego cos'è cos'è che ci sono solo spine
dico come dovrei fare come ho fatto a ho
capito no fermi lega fosse forse oca
forse devo saltare dalla parte opposta
tipo così emma beh ma sei stronzo è
impossibile soli verna fermi nativa eh
va beh io già non riesco a fare super
meat boy normale che dove fare questo ma
io posso volare o cosa non ho capito a
figo vabbè ma di te che cazzo ne so io
ok ok bene lo inglobata non è finita
come contro dura sta roba hai fatto di
capire se non riesco [ __ ] continua
laddove niente non riesco cioè non
riuscirò mai nella vita falso eva allora
sei stronzo
ma basta mi sono rotto il cazzo exit ma
è non è così io già non riesco a fare
super meat boy normale mi devi anche
cagare il cazzo ok ok
sì sì sì era difficile da fare la
difficile no perché ci metti la vita
allora non ci posso mai eccepito più
grosso allora prossimo che mi manda un
messaggio lo chiama lo uccido a di
quella di quella donna di ju ju bravo no
ma perché è tanto difficile andare giù
perfetto se è difficile evidentemente è
difficile sentite calmi ma perché prima
ci passava adesso no si no cosa sto
facendo
sì sì sì sì grade a ho preso anche ha
inciso credenze geas turkcell macchia a
c'è anche la chiave mancava solo quello
guarda ci sono adesso prendo la chiave
dove sia da tornare all'inizio perfetto
calmo ok o supposta la prendiamo non la
prendiamo perché non mi sembra niente
bene l'importante è esserci riusciti ci
sono le chiavi a destra come va bene ma
se volete metterci qualcos'altro non ci
riuscirò mai nella vita
duecento anni neanche ma sono tutti così
i prossimi ma ditemelo ok ok non osso
con non fate domande perfetto qua c'è un
howard non per forza perché nero però
non la prenderò comunque perché non mite
ma che cos'è oggi queste trappole e
impossibile calmi che ci fa ci passo ci
passano di preoccupati
ci passo non ci passo cipresso aver
sentito lo prendo e sto fermo poi parto
ok no no no io no ok veloce ci sono
regali bellissimo se non ci credete
stavo anche per morire però non vorrei
dire però che va bene così non voglio
ditto ha bevuto red bull red perché li
ha messo le ali
va bè a quanto strana sta roba comunque
ok no no no ti prego
si ok c'era una chiave cosa mi infilavo
nel ca pranzi la chiave gay
ok calmi quest'app è ok loci non mi sto
spiegando questa cosa ragazzino mi devo
fare tipo il video in mutande ma perché
parlo
[Musica]
mi vergogno di queste cose per cortesia
non fate screen va bene cosa sta uscendo
story 2 devo andare lì con il nostro
calcolano di sotto che più incasinato
quindi vado di sotto perfetto madonna
dove sono passato sono cadute le cuffie
ci regala alla prua gene è mai vista
problema beh ma siete basta ragazzi
questo è la scena più triste che abbia
mai visto in tutta la mia vita c'è che
anzi ragazzi sta diventando una roba su
cos'è
mi sembra invece ok la chiave cielo è la
madonna cos'è st comi qaeda e da cinema
d'azione ce l'ho fatta prendo a più per
forza perché non c'è come no è meglio è
meglio di così come potevo farla non ho
capito sono vari club è a caso si no
devo saltare però ma cos'è ma io non ho
mano dai maschi per questo è uno scherzo
davvero impossibile ok vabbè non importa
basta che ce la fai
sì ha ringraziato gesù e così no sì c'è
l'ansia mille ok che su su su su su su
bravo zio no devi devi andare proprio
solo finché non timore la mamma proprio
finché deve sentire la mamma che muore
perfetto bravo no non deve morire la
mamma non ti chiama bye bye bye va o no
siccome ok no ma perché ti deve morire
la famiglia c'è spiegamelo è bene allora
sì sì sì basta lega vi prego non ci sto
credendo mai che sono arrivato al boss
che poi ragazzi sta inglobando amica ha
pensato malissimo subito è stata la
causa bruttissima che fa eco lui non
capisce giustamente si bastardo forte
però ragazzi non ho capito una roba
questo doveva essere un ospedale che
cazzo ci aveva d'ospedale stoffa parte
le supposte vabbè che è successo mi ha
detto mega evoluzione a dio salire mi
piace a tre denti è la madonna e canzoni
che non aspetta un bruttissimo ai
mondali sopra prima che lui salga come
faccio a dio sta succedendo ragazzo
aiuto no c'era una chiave che ho
dimenticato non sono morto sicuro invece
no non sono morto morto non so non sono
morto perché sono [ __ ] sotto di
sottodiciotto di sotto di sottodiciotto
veloce veloce lo sci anche spunti come
cioè si ho schivato veloci dove vado
dove che salgo di qua che cazzo cani
regal cani dove dove finale vedercela
chiave lì come la raggiungo come c'è
un'altra chiave 18 e la madonna che
casino ma è caduta madonna si è morto ci
ho fatto vinto rito serio momix spunta
un altro livello no vinto intonaci che
non ci sto credendo ragazzo ha messo
pochissimo non pensavo di 25 e morto
bene mister ragazzi non mi piace
verdetto puccioso che e molto piu figo
del dito normale che fa quello l'asta
sodomizzando la tipa però va bene ei
bellissimi mi sono innamorato lascia la
tipa e mettiti con lui che è la cosa più
tenera che manda i baci a cazzo ma no mi
dispiace di attirato un case idiota
anche tu era così puccioso cosa l'asta
stuprando fai qualcosa dio mio eva ben
fatti dare una mano da ditte non tanto
per lei calciato quindi col cazzo ancora
ma basta
dovrebbe essere una tipa penso perché
sia innamorata di cosa fa lo va a
prendere ma cosa fa cos'è successo credo
di aver preso detto come personaggio non
so qualcosa del genere perchè non è
andato lì con lo scott ex vecchio
ragazzi ho concluso the hospital anche
questo son riuscito a finirlo con tutti
i livelli cosa che non capita la
praticamente mai il prossimo è la
fabbrica di sao che lo fanno ragazzi
la prossima parte con clock l'episodio
credo che editto meriti li mi piace
perché pucci pucci che questo di poi si
è rovinato però è un son dettagli e
quindi ragazzi servito è piaciuto ma sai
lasciato momento mi piace anche al
presente di facebook e come nei video
trovate descrizione sensori city
scrivetemi ci vediamo un po se ho vinto
belle ragazze